Podcast Ufo, hör gut zu, denn dann kommst du endlich zur Ruh. So wie Napo Leon vor Rotterlou, so wie mittags unter dem Baum das Gnu, so springt über den Gartenzaun einühl, Podcast, den ihr euch wie eine warme Decke über den Kopf ziehen könnt. Hallo Stefan Tietze, ein Kissen, auf das ich mich jederzeit legen und ausruhen kann. Hallo Stefan. Und Florentin Will, der Zitronentee, bündet mir jedes Mal aufs neue Reinkippe und nicht dazulerne, denn er ist, wie immer, zu heiß. Christoph, vielen, vielen Dank für dieses tolle Intro, das mich wirklich an meine alten Tage erinnert hat. Welche, welche, welche. Ich bin so Olli-Schulz-Musik durch Berlin gezogen, bin wirklich in Träumereien in den Himmel geschaut, habe wirklich die grossen Gefühle, habe mein Herz durchschwappt und ich war melancholisch, aber gleichzeitig lyrisch, künstlerisch, ganz, ganz toll. Ich habe letztens ein paar alte Texte von mir gelesen, ganz, ganz grauenvoll. Die du dann... Ganz, ganz grauenvoll. Ich hatte so ein, ich habe mir extra so ein Buch gekauft und dann habe ich gesagt, genau, und dann habe ich gesagt, ich schreibe jeden Tag drei Seiten. Und dann habe ich mir das vorgenommen und ich glaube, ich habe es drei Tage durchgezogen, aber diese neun Seiten, reinste Erbärmlichkeit, habe ich noch. Ich möchte mal gerne die Ratio wissen, jetzt würde ich gerne die Firma Moleskine. Das ist ja auch eigentlich so ein geiler Marketing-Coup von denen, zu sagen, wie viele Moleskines da draußen wurden nur zu ein, zwei Prozent beschrieben. Ja, so eine Statistik, so elf Prozent ist die durchschnittliche Seitenzahl eines Moleskins, der tatsächlich beschrieben wurde. Genau, aber ich will so, und dann kannst du dann als Werbung, ich weiß schon, ihr wollt dann auch promoten, wie toll ein Produkt ist, dann könnt ihr so, hast du übergehen, was sind die Leute, die das vollschreiben, was haben die gerade gemacht, aber Leute, so Larrys wie wir, die schreiben immer nur, ich habe ganz viele Moleskines zu Hause, weil ich die einfach toll finde, optisch toll finde, man fühlt sich gut an der Kasse und dann schreibt man zwei Seiten. Ich habe ganz viele, auf denen ich auch so selbstbewusst bin, man kann ja vorne reinschreiben, muss man seinen Namen reinschreiben, dann so Thema und ich habe so viele Moleskines, wo so ein Thema, so sehr spezifisch, wo ich so eine Serienidee oder so eine Filmidee hatte, wo das so gross, habe ich mir so Mühe gegeben, so gross Capitals reingeschrieben habe vorne drin. Und jetzt fühle ich mich so reulich, weil ich das jetzt so nicht mehr dafür benutze, weil das natürlich nach drei Stunden nachdenken denkt, man, was für eine Quatschidee. Das einzige, was man in Moleskens schreibt, ist Enttäuschung. das Einzige, was man daraus lesen kann. Ich hatte sogar so ein Buch mit so einem Magneten, den man so umklappen konnte, wo man dann hinten überklappen konnte und wirklich mit so einem Band auch, damit man auf jeden Fall nicht verliert, wo man gerade liest, sein eigengeschriebenes Buch. Keine Angst, Moleskens, ich werde nicht vergessen, wo ich bin, auf Seite zwei. Über die neun Seiten kann ich den Überblick behalten, keine Sorgen. Ganz, ganz grässlich geschrieben. Ich war damals schon sehr faul. Da war ich so im Studium, Anfang Studium, 18, 19 irgendwie und dachte mir, ich will viel schreiben und meinen Stil verbessern und so richtig rein und habe einen Stil. Genau. Ja, guter Punkt. Und ich kann dir meinen Stil relativ gut beschreiben. Extrem abgehobener, möchte gern intellektuelles Arschloch, das so jeden zweiten Satz mit dem furchtbaren Wort zumal beginnt. Ein Red Flag eines Wortes. Und ich habe das gelesen und ich denke mir, schreibt doch nicht ständig zumal, das ist das schlimmste Wort, das es gibt.
Folgende Wörter sind die absolute Red Flag und markieren aber dadurch Gott sei Dank auch pretentious assholes. Zumal, wir machen abwechselnd, zumal, so krank von dir jetzt, nichtsdestoweniger. Ja, genau, so dann. Im Englischen das. Genau, diese dummen Worte, die man einfach ersetzen kann, auch durch nichts. Zumal man sagen muss, dass natürlich die Betrachtung so ist. Dieses furchtbare Benutzung. Das Wort nun auch nicht geil. Nun muss man aber dazu sagen, fuck you. Ganz furchtbar. Ganz schrecklich. Inhaltlich natürlich ganz, ganz absolut katastrophal. Aber das Wort zumal ist mir am meisten aufgestossen und ganz, ganz furchtbar. Letztlich? Letztlich, ja, genau, Spannungsfeld, nee, ganz, ganz furchtbar, aber ich habe nämlich letztens zu dem Anlass viele alte Leute aus meiner Schul- und Studienzeit getroffen und habe dann so ein bisschen in Nostalgie geschwälgt und habe auch so ein paar meiner alten Aufzeichnungen rausgeholt und so auch Tagebuch und sowas in der Richtung. Hast du mal geschrieben, regelmäßig? Nicht regelmäßig, ich habe nichts in meinem Leben vernünftig mal durchgezogen. Weil bei Tagebuchenden ist auch bei mir immer so, die ersten zwei Seiten sind beschrieben. Genau, bei mir ist immer so irgendwie so 18. August 2001, 19. August 2001, 20. August 2001. War schon in Klammern merklich weniger. Ja, und dann 4. Dezember
2013.
Wir überspringen einfach so
zwölf Jahre,
sind einfach übersprungen, mordlos,
niemand, und das ist dann so
und ganz, ganz furchtbar. Aber
muss man immer mal wieder machen, einfach um
zu wissen, ah, ich war
genau, ich war wirklich auch verachtenswert.
Ich würde mich selbst von früher verachten
und man sollte vielleicht mal so ein bisschen die Zügel
anlegen, wenn man heute Leute verachtet oder die
In zu wissen, ah, ich war genau, ich war wirklich auch verachtenswert. Ich würde mich selbst von früher verachten und man sollte vielleicht mal so ein bisschen die Zügel anlegen, wenn man heute Leute verachtet oder die irgendwie unsympathisch rüberkommen und so. Ja, war ich auch mal so irgendwie mit so super prätentiös und super tolle Gedanken und so furchtbar. Es ist spannend, dass du, weil wir machen einen Podcast ja seit elf Jahren, also in gewisser Weise ist das ja ein Tagebuch. Auch, ja, ich glaube auch, wenn wir uns jetzt die ersten Podcast-Suche-Folgen anhören würden, würden wir da
nicht gut durchkommen, glaube ich.
Das gehört natürlich dazu.
Bei mir ist neulich WhatsApp,
irgendwie passiert das
häufig mal, dass man plötzlich unten
ist bei WhatsApp in dem
Chat, die
springt da so runter, man weiß nicht,
welchen Knopf habe ich gedrückt, dann muss ich jetzt mal die Brille, wandert dann so hoch und dann muss ich erstmal gucken. Und dann ist die Schriftart so klein, ich fühle mich sehr alt währenddessen, aber dann ist so runtergesprungen. Und dann war ich so bei so ganz alten Gruppen und da habe ich mal so geguckt, was da so war. Und da habe ich tatsächlich eine Gruppe gefunden zur Zeit der Abi-Zeit, so Abi-Show-Zeit. Und da habe ich gemerkt, huiuiuiui, zurückblickend habe ich Leute abgestempelt als irre Arschlöcher oder so, Wichser, arrogant, haben mich schlecht von oben herab behandelt, dann liest man diese Nachrichten und denkt sich, oder war ich das Problem? Oder wer war das Problem eigentlich? Erwachsen werden heißt auch, zu merken, dass man auch selber das Problem war. Die eigenen Unzulänglichkeiten zu erkennen und so in gewisser Weise so Geschichtsrelativismus betreiben muss. Ja, okay. Nicht, ich meine jetzt eigenem, im eigenen Sinne. Okay, aha. Nee, ich meine das jetzt nicht im gesamten Geschichte-Kontext. Ich meine, die eigene Biografie zu untersuchen, auf festgeschrieben, zu glauben, festgeschriebene Werte und Normen, die immer bestehen, das ist nicht unbedingt richtig. Ja, ja. Ganz, ganz furchtbar auch so, Facebook ist da auch herrlich. Facebook, die uralten Nachrichten kann man ja bei den Nachrichten ganz runterscrollen. So die allerersten Nachrichten, die man 2008 oder was auch immer, ganz vor furchtbar langer Zeit geschrieben hat, ganz, ganz, ganz schrecklich. Ganz furchtbar. Schrecklich, ja. Muss man untersuchen, muss man genau gucken, was da genau passiert, muss man untersuchen und dann eine Kommission einleiten, die untersucht, wie es besser geht.
Jugend sünden und natürlich du als Autor wirst das ja mitbekommen haben, es ging eine Schockwelle durch die Literaturwelt Deutschlands, der Bundesrepublik, ausgelöst durch unseren Podcast.
Tatsächlich, wir haben da anscheinend einen wunden Punkt getroffen, wir haben da tatsächlich was erwischt, was einen grösseren Diskurs angestossen hat. Stefan, kannst du uns einleiten? Naja, also wo soll man anfangen, wo soll man aufhören? Ich glaube, das Thema steht für sich allein. Ja, in der Tat, aber ich würde es trotzdem noch mal ergänzend hier einführen. Es geht natürlich um den Kinderbuch-Klassiker der Regenbogenfisch.
Ich habe es angesprochen, die Wellen geschlagen. Die Wogen schlagen hoch. Und tatsächlich, ich weiß nicht, ob es Zufall ist, aber auf der, ja, ich würde sagen, Auf dem Schweizer Literaturbrecher-Blog 20min.ch kam am 4. April dieses Jahres um 5 Uhr morgens, also relativ kurze Zeit nach unserer Folge, kam ein Artikel, also jetzt stellt sich der Autor den Fragen, der internationale Klassiker der Regenbogenfisch steht in der Kritik, die Botschaft sei fragwürdig und problematisch. Was? Jetzt gibt der Schweizer Autor Markus Pfister Kontext. Es könnte reiner Zufall sein, aber es kam wirklich direkt nach dem, wie das im Podcast. Man kann ja den Satz, also jetzt, 20 Minuten und CH ist es auch nicht die Sperrspitze des Schweizer Journalismus, muss man ganz klar so sagen. Da muss man auch zu sagen, dass wir keine Ahnung von der Schweizer Literaturszene haben. Das heißt, das kann natürlich... Ja, also du nicht, aber ja, genau. Okay. So, und jetzt muss man aber zu sagen, man kann ja nicht sagen, der muss sich der Kritik stellen, hat sich der Kritik jetzt endlich gestellt, man muss ja dann schon nochmal sagen, was für eine Kritik... Ja, richtig, ne, also... Worauf bezieht sich denn der Artikelikel? Also das Problem ist, der Regenbogenfisch ist ein extrem beliebtes Kinderbuch, weil die Schuppen glitzern. Kinder mögen das, wenn es glitzert im Buch. Aber es gibt natürlich hinter dieser schalen glitzernden Oberfläche noch eine Geschichte. Und ich habe es schon besprochen, mein Problem mit dem Regenbogenfisch ist, der Regenbogenfisch unterscheidet sich von anderen Fischen in drei Punkten. Erstens, er ist bunt, deswegen heisst er der Regenbogenfisch, eine Eigenschaft, die niemals zur Rede kommt. In dem gesamten Buch geht es nie darum, dass der Regenbogenfisch, der so heisst, weil er bunt ist, bunt ist, sondern es geht um die Schuppen, die er hat. Er hat aber auch noch Glitzerflossen. Er hat auch Glitzerschuppen. Und grob gesagt, er ist der einzige Fisch im Meer, der diese Glitzerschuppen hat. Und am Ende verteilt er die Schuppen an andere Fische, sodass alle eine Schuppe haben. Er behält eine Schuppe und alle anderen Fische haben auch jeweils eine Schuppen. Schuppensozialismus. Allerdings hat er weiterhin Glitzerflossen, die die anderen nicht haben, die man auch nicht verteilen kann? Wofür stehen die metaphorisch? Und er ist weiterhin der einzige Fisch, der bunt ist, die anderen Fische nicht. Kommt überhaupt nicht zur Sprache. Also ganz, ganz viele fragliche Dinge. Was ist denn die Botschaft? Man muss Leute bezahlen, damit sie mit einem spielen. Leute müssen ihre Besonderheiten an andere weitergeben, alle müssen gleich sein am Ende,
es kann erst gespielt werden, wenn alle
gleich sind, es geht nicht, dass einer Glitzerschuppen
hat und die anderen nicht, es ist
auch wirklich unklar. So,
jetzt ein Artikel von Josephine Schertenleib.
Josephine, falls du dich
gerade angesprochen fühlst und Hörerin
bist, melde dich gerne, mich würde wirklich interessieren,
ob du hier
Inspiration gefunden hast, wir sind bereit, mit dir diesen Kreuzzug zu gehen. Denn jetzt geht's los.
So, das Kinderbuch Regenbogenfisch wird wegen seiner Botschaft hinterfragt.
Im Interview mit 20 Minuten betont Autor Markus Pfister, kommen wir gleich dazu, jetzt stellt sich Markus Pfister nämlich hier den Attacken.
So, Herr Pfister, welche Botschaft wollten Sie Kindern mit Ihrem Buch vermitteln? Das ist ja alles irre. So, und Herr Pfister antwortet, ich habe viele Bücher geschrieben. Okay, als jetzt mal ganz selbstneutral. Ich weiß, ich bin irgendwie in diesem Feuergefecht irgendwo mittendrin, lauf so herum.
Jetzt nur so aus einer PR-Sicht der Satz, ich habe viele Bücher geschrieben, auf eine Frage, die danach nicht fragt, zu sagen ist immer eher unsympathisch. Ich habe viele Bücher geschrieben und mein Ziel war nie, ein moralisches Buch zu schreiben. Zumal in manchen, nein, das war jetzt ein Gag von mir, in manchen Geschichten lässt sich eine Moral leichter einbauen als in anderen, wobei oft danach gesucht wird. So verstehe ich auch, dass der... Das ist eine Seite lieber an dich, das ist eine erste Seite lieber an dich. Man sucht Moral, wo vielleicht keine ist. So verstehe ich auch, dass der Regenbogenfisch als eine Geschichte über das Teilen gesehen wird. Ja.
Aha. Für mich stand jedoch etwas anderes im Mittelpunkt.
Ja, bunte Flossen verkaufen.
Der Regenbogenfisch ist ein Anti-Held.
Am Anfang ist er überheblich, arrogant und unnahbar. Er meinte, dass er die Stimme der Stimme der Stimme der Stimme der Stimme der Stimme der Stimme der Stimme der St nicht dafür, wie er aussieht. So, Herr Pfister, erstmal, das ist nicht die Definition eines Anti-ihelden. Nee, und zu sagen, ihm ging es nicht darum, eine Moral zu schreiben und dann eine Moral zu beschreiben, die vielleicht eine andere ist, genau, Punkt eins, Punkt zwei, das ist nicht die Definition eines Antihelden. Antiheld ist ein Protagonist, der was Böses macht, wie Walter White in Breaking Bad oder Tony Soprano oder sowas. Ja, jemand, der einer bösen Ideologie folgt zum Beispiel und nicht jemand, der offensichtlich etwas lernen muss oder auf dem Weg ist, etwas zu lernen. Der Regenbogenfisch ist ein klassischer Held. Er hat Probleme und Fehler und die überkommt er und am Ende sind alle glücklich. Und er muss lernen, sich zu öffnen und dafür geschätzt zu werden, wer er ist, nicht dafür, wie er aussieht. Das ergibt keinen Sinn. Alle mögen ihn doch, weil er sein Aussehen an die anderen weitergibt, weil er die Schuppen weitergibt. Und wie gesagt, Herr Pfister, gib ihm doch nicht zwei weitere Merkmale, die Glitzerflossen und die bunten Schuppen, wenn es nicht darum geht, wie er aussieht. Also das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
So, was man jetzt mal mitnehmen könnte, wenn man ihm jetzt das Beste unterstellt, ist, er gibt die Sachen ab, um gleich auszusehen, so weit er das kann, um dafür geliebt zu werden, was er ist. Er muss ja erstmal was abgeben, damit er so aussieht wie die anderen, um, klar, für die Flossen kann er nichts, aber er möchte ja so, vielleicht will der Fisch gemocht sehen, ey, ich bin auch mehr, also, also angenommen, du bist jetzt mit Podcast-Uwe-Fans befreundet, so, sehr theoretisch, sehr theoretisch, ja, okay, aber ich versuche mich hineinzuversetzen. Und du möchtest irgendwann geliebt werden für das, was du bist, Florentin Will. Okay. Und nicht die Florentin Will-Persona im Podcast-Ufo oder auch nicht für den Podcast an sich oder das, genau, nicht für die Idee. Okay. So, jetzt angenommen, das wären deine Flossen. Also die Flossen stehen für deinen Podcast.
Deine Achievements, was auch immer.
Die leugnet er sozusagen,
reißt er sich aus, nimmt ihn weg.
Damit wir uns nicht verlaufen.
Redest du wirklich von Flossen oder meinst du Schuppen? Das dachte ich mir.
Ja, die Flossen ist der grösste Curveball,
der in der Geschichte von Moral-Kinderbücher.
Okay, also ja. Meine Schuppen, mit denen ich mich schmücke, sind mein Erfolg und der Podcast. Okay. So, er leugnet sich so ein bisschen, weil er geliebt werden will für das, was er ist. Das Problem ist ja... Aber dann ist er kein Arschloch und nicht überheblich. Also das ist so, wo kommt das denn dann her? Und du hast auch gesagt, es gab keinen Trigger-Moment. Nein, nein, nein. Am Anfang der Geschichte ist er überheblich und sagt, oh, ich bin der Schönste, ich brauche euch nicht. Und deswegen ist er unbeliebt. Nicht, weil er schön ist oder diese Glitzerschuppen hat oder anders ist, sondern weil er aus seiner Andersartigkeit eine Überheblichkeit macht. Er sagt, ich bin anders als ihr, also bin ich besser als ihr. Und deswegen mögen ihn die anderen Fische nicht. Würde er einfach sagen, hey Leute, lass uns zusammen spielen, kein Problem, alles cool, kann er trotzdem noch seine Individualität bewahren, als Aussenseiter, als Glitzerfisch, aber er ist Teil der Gruppe. Aber nein, die Geschichte sagt uns, er muss seine Individualität aufgeben, er verteilt die Schuppen, damit alle gleich sind, alle diese Schuppen haben, er also nicht mehr individuell ist, bis auf die Glitzerflossen und die bunten Schuppen, die nicht zur Sprache kommen, kein einziges Mal. Also was genau ist es? Anti-Held. Wir haben auch eine Nachricht bekommen im Reddit, wo es heißt, es geht darum, seine Weirdness mit anderen zu teilen, also sozusagen nicht alles für sich zu haben, sondern auch das, was einen einzigartig macht, mit anderen zu teilen. Es kann metaphorisch natürlich funktionieren, man gibt seine Körperteile, die Schuppen weg,
aber es ist nur ein Teil.
Viel spannender finde ich ja diesen
Mac Zuckerbergschen, also um jetzt
The Social Network mal damit als Analogie zu kommen,
Fehlschluss,
dass es seine
Schuppen sind,
die ihm abgrenzen
von den anderen und nicht
seine Arschlochhaftigkeit.
Genau.
Also, du wirst durch die Welt schwimmen und denken, alle hassen dich, weil du anders bist mit deinen Flossen. Genau. Du musst durch die Welt schwimmen und merken, nein, die mögen dich nicht, weil du ein Arschloch bist. Ich finde, der Regenbogenfisch ist nicht der, der sich verändern sollte in der Geschichte. Weil die anderen Fische kommen an und sagen, gib uns von deinen Schuppen, gib uns von deinen Schuppen.
Und der Regenbogenfisch sagt, nein, fickt euch, das sind meine Schuppen.
Als Leser denkst du dir, ja, du bist zwar arrogant, aber hier hast du einen Punkt.
Und dann am Ende der Geschichte... Aber jetzt sind wir in der Umverteilungsdiskussion.
Und die Fische, eigentlich sollten die Fische am Ende sagen,
hey, wir können auch mit dir befreundet sein, ohne dass du uns was gibst, deine Anwesenheit und deine... Oder halt, takes the rich. Ja. Weil jetzt ist das der alleinerziehende Clownsfischvater, der halt, der kommt halt so gerade über die Runden. Und weisst du, wie was inzwischen irgendwie ein paar Algen kosten, wie viele Flossen oder Schuppen
ja, aber ja, okay
es ist wirklich unklar, so, es geht weiter
sie wissen aber, dass ihr Buch
aktuell zumindest vielfach anders gelesen
ist. Von wem?
sag mal, du hast in einem luftleeren
Raum, hast du diese
wer liest
wer bespricht noch den Regenbogenfisch?
ja, niemand checkt dieses Buch
und Eltern in der ganzen Welt
Werden wir In deren Raum hast du diese ... Wer bespricht noch den Regenbogenfisch?
Ja, niemand checkt dieses Buch.
Und Eltern in der ganzen Welt werden wahrscheinlich Fragen von ihren Kindern bekommen und können sie nicht beantworten, weil dies auch keinen Sinn ergibt.
Dieses Datum ist des Zufalls zu viel.
Das weiss ich nicht. So, Pfister antwortet.
Ja, das weiss ich, und es erstaunt mich immer wieder, wie so ein kleines Buch so verschieden interpretiert werden kann. Als ob die Grösse des Buches irgendwas damit zu tun hat. Genau, nicht die dicke. Also nicht die dicke oder die Länge der Geschichte, sondern die grösse und das Format. Das ist ein formelles Problem. Beim Kinderbücher sind immer kurz. Ich meine, das gehört dazu. So, weiter geht's. Ein Vorwurf ist, dass der Regenbogenfisch einen Teil von sich, sogar seinen Körper, abgeben muss, um akzeptiert zu werden. Ja, die Prostitution. Pfister, diese Lesart kann ich mir nur so erklären, dass Betroffene das Buch nicht genau lesen. Auf der zweiten Doppelseite sieht man nämlich, dass der Regenbogenfisch nicht ein Opfer ist, das zur Anpassung gezwungen wird, im Gegenteil, die anderen Fische wollen von Anfang an mit ihm spielen, doch er ist zu sehr mit seinem eigenen Glanz beschäftigt. Wichtig ist auch, dass im Buch von einem Schuppenkleid die Rede
ist. Ein Symbol für etwas
Äusseres, das man besitzt,
wie etwa teure Sneakers.
Jetzt sind aber, also
jetzt rein anatomisch
Schuppen
ein Körperteil
der Fische. Ja.
Das ist nichts, was sie sich anziehen oder suchen.
Dann nimm halt die Muschel, nimm halt die Regenbogenmuschel Krebs. Nimm die Einsiedlerkrebs, ja sowas in der Richtung. Wie man besitzt wie etwa teure Sneaker und nicht für etwas, das man wirklich isst. Deshalb kann und darf der Regenbogenfisch am Ende des Buches Teile dieses Schuppenkleides an andere abgeben. Frage, verliert der Regenbogenfisch dadurch nicht seine Individualität? Auf keinen Fall, auch ohne glitzernde Schuppen bleibt er erkennbar. Genau darum geht es, es ist der Charakter, der eine Person und ihre wahre Schönheit ausmacht. Es bleiben ein paar Fragen offen. Was hat er noch geschrieben? Er hat viele Bücher geschrieben. Ja genau, damit hält er ja nicht in den Berg. Einige kritisieren auch, dass die Freundschaften des Regenbogenfisches am Ende nur auf der oberflächlichen Vergabe von Glitzerschuppen beruhen. Wie stehen sie dazu? Hier kommt wieder Seite zwei ins Spiel. Sehr viel passiert auf Seite zwei. Ein Kern, die geschickte scheint ins Spiel. Vielleicht war das bei den meisten Büchern verklebt oder so, wir wissen es nicht. Ja, oder weil Kinder da so lange daran knabbern, dass die Seite zwei weg ist. Ich finde das so geil, wenn Autor sich immer wieder auf Seite zwei seines Buches mitzutzt. Ja, aber es gibt nur sechs. Das ist eine Seite. Wie ich bereits auf Seite zwei geschriebenlammern ein Drittel des Buches. Hier kommt wieder Seite zwei ins Spiel. Die anderen kleinen Fische, auch gut, kleinen Fische, wollten von Beginn an mit ihm spielen, bevor er überhaupt danach gefragt wurde, seine Schuppen zu teilen. Er hätte also einfach nett Nein sagen können. Aber die Entscheidung, seine glitzernden Schuppen zu teilen, bereitet ihm auch Freude. Etwas zu verschenken, das einem selbst wichtig ist und andere nicht haben, kann durchaus eine positive Frage sein. Fragen die nicht die ganze Zeit nach seinen Schuppen am Anfang schon? Am Anfang kann sein, dass sie am Anfang nicht fragen, aber am Ende fragen sie es schon danach. Als großer Kritiker, trägt auf dem Shirt, Texte, Rainbow Fish, der muss solche Fakten haben. Wenn die den fragen. Ja, nee, aber sie fragen ihn später schon, da kommt der kleine Fisch, dann sagt er nochmal nein. Und dann, was ich auch bemängele, kommt ein unerklärter Gewissensschwung und er sagt, ah, okay, nee, doch, ich gebe euch doch die Schuppen. Ist klar, du sagst jetzt, es gibt dem Tintenfisch diese Orakelfigur, diese der weise Figur, die ihm sagt, man soll die Schuppen. Der Mentor, der Gandaligur. Genau, den weist er aber ab. Das ist sowieso ganz merkwürdig. So, und jetzt kommt natürlich der Knaller zum Schluss. In Florida hat eine Bibliothek ihr Buch 2022 aus dem Sortiment genommen. Nein. Antwort, das ist natürlich schade. Aber Fakt ist, The Rainbow Fish gehört zu den beliebtesten nicht-anglophonen Büchern überhaupt in den USA. Es ist also viel mehr von positiven Rückmeldungen betroffen, als von Zensuren. Zensuren. Ja, Pfister, ich sage, oh, ui, ui, Ui, Pfister, die Macht Gottes. Pfister sabotiert hier schon unser Mikrofon-Setup. Ja, also ganz spannend, ganz Deutschland und die Schweiz, der ganze Dachraum, glaube ich, kann man mal sagen, diskutiert über der Regenbogenfisch. So, die schon beste Region. Ich finde aber zu Recht, weil dieses Buch ergibt keinen Sinn. und allein die Tatsache, dass der Regenbogenfisch Regenbogenfisch heisst, wahrscheinlich wegen seiner bunten Schuppen, das aber nie zur Sprache kommt, irritiert mich maximal. Kennst du der kleine Dino von Marcus Pfister? Nein. Ich glaube, der ist leider auch einer dieser wenigen Künstler, die wirklich auf ein Werk reduziert werden. Als Kinderbuchautor, es gibt halt nur fünf Kinderbücher. Also die Schränkung, die ist natürlich ganz offensichtlich. Also wenn er mit dem Satz beginnt, ich habe sehr viele Bücher geschrieben, ich habe unzählige Bücher geschrieben. Ich habe endlos viele Bücher geschrieben. Ja, ich hatte ja ein Poesiealbum vom Regenbogenfisch. Es gibt ja verschiedene Poesiealben, verschiedenen Designs, Asterix, Diddle oder so und ich hatte von der Regenbogenfisch. Poesiealben war der Euphemismus des Jahrhunderts. Welche Poesie steht im Poesiealbum? Eigentlich sollte jeder ein Gedicht reinschreiben. Bei mir war es leider so, das erste hat irgendeine Klassenkameradin reingeschrieben, lebe lustig und sei froh wie der Mops im Haferstroh. Und dann die Nächsten haben Bist du in den Sechzigern gross geworden? Wie viel älter bist du? Ich bin älter, als man denkt tatsächlich. Man sieht es mir zu Glück noch nicht an. Nein, du bist inzwischen auch schon 200 Jahre alt. Ich bin so eine Dorian Gray-Figur, die dann schlagartig altert. Und tatsächlich alle weiteren Einträge haben dann geschrieben, lebe lustig und sei froh wie die Laus im Haferstroh. Und ich dachte mir als Kind schon, wollt ihr mich verarschen? Ich bin auf der Suche nach Poesie, ich suche Poesie und ich kriege einfach nur Remixes von diesem ersten Gedicht, ganz furchtbar. Ist die Idee eines Poesiealbums eigentlich mal gewesen, dass man Gedichte von seinen Liebsten sammelt? Kann gut sein. Wie damals ein paar Verse, ein paar Verse wurden geschenkt, als Hochzeitsgeschenk. Da steht da schon, da steht immer so eine große Box mit hier ein paar Zeilen für dich, was man dann irgendwie schreibt oder halt irgendwie Nikolas Ambrosius oder wie auch immer. Und halt natürlich dieser Steckbrief mit was will ich mal werden und so und alles, ja. Ich gucke nämlich gerade die Buddenbrooks. Es gibt die Buddenbrooks. Also ich glaube, es ist eine elfteilige Serie.
Ja, also von 1978.
Vom Regisseur Franz Peter Wirth.
Und die gibt es komplett bei YouTube.
In drei Teile.
Ich glaube, die wurde auch mal dann aufgeteilt.
Es ist glaube ich eine Serie.
Ich verstehe es nicht ganz, weil unter dem gleichen
Namen mit der Jahreszahl
findet man eine Serie.
Aber was ich bei YouTube sehe, ist ein dreiteiliger Epos, wie so ein Dreiteiler. Filme, drei Filme. Wie so drei Filme, ja. Und ein bisschen serieller erzählt, aber wie die Buddenburgs ja auch, so teilweise so Epochen, dann beschrieben werden, dann gibt es einen harten Bruch und dann geht es ein paar Jahre später weiter, aber super spannend. Und diese Zeit ist ultra geil. Also wir würden sofort auffliegen, weil diese ganz strengen Normen, nachdem man das, da gibt es diese tolle Figur von Alois Permaneda, dem, und da merkt man auch so ein bisschen, was Thomas Mann über München denkt, und die Münchner ist ja bekannt, ja. der ist jemand, der so gar nichts mit dieser Tüchtigkeit der Lübecker, der Handelsstadt so anfangen kann. Der ist ein bisschen gemütlicher. Der ist ein bisschen gemütlicher und dann ist er auch irritiert, dass es da keine grossen Biere gibt, sondern nur so kleine Gläser und dann heiratet der Toni Buddenbrook, nur um sich dann mit der Mitgift zur Ruhe zu setzen. Geil, also schnell, schnell geht das erst einmal gar nix. Und ich finde das so eine lustige Figur und dann geht es eigentlich darum, dass Toni, ja, das ganze Kapitel Männer an den Nagel hängt und es ist so ein bisschen so, wie ich mir, ich habe es nie geguckt, aber so Downton Abbey oder The Crown oder so vorstelle, nur in Deutsch und ein bisschen älter. Aber ich liebe die Outfits, ich liebe die Dialoge, ich finde es total geil. Also, großer, großer Tipp von mir, Franz Peter Wehr, die Buddenbrooks, könnt ihr angucken. Ich erinnere mich nämlich vor allem da sehr gerne nostalgisch dran zurück, weil ich das damals nicht lesen wollte im Abi, sondern dachte, wie kann ich mir das trotzdem irgendwie full length geben. Ich glaube auch sowas wie Audioformat oder so Hörbücher gab es damals noch nicht so richtig so zugänglich und das habe ich damals dann geguckt und ich habe mich da sehr gerne daran zurückgeerinnert. Ach warum. Auch weil ich den Norden, wo ich letztes Jahr war, Travemünde, gibt es nämlich auch da, weil da fahren die immer hin.
Und du hast es damals komplett geguckt, oder wie? Ja, wenn denen nämlich die Decke auf den Kopf fällt im umtriebigen Lübeck, dann geht es an die Ostsee, nach Travemünde, wegen der guten Luft, weil da das Klima besser ist. Also wirklich ganz, ganz toll, schaut euch das unbedingt an. Also ganz, ganz tolle Kostüme und man, die Immersion ist crazy, weil für mich als jemand, der jetzt so 25 lebt, ist er 1978 sehr weit weg. Und es macht keinen Unterschied, weil das spielt irgendwann 1890, whatever, man checkt nicht mehr, also es verfliesst komplett. Es verfliesst das Alter des Jahrzehnts, in dem es gedreht wurde, mit dem, wo es eigentlich spielt und es ist einfach ein toller Blick in die Vergangenheit. Man denkt, es sind Originalaufnahmen eigentlich von damals. Ja, man denkt wirklich, es ist eine Dokumentation. Also kann ich nur empfehlen. Wenn man mal 19 Stunden Zeit hat, kann man sich das mal schön gehen. Einfach einen sehr langen Flug, einmal komplett um die Erde. Ja, so, und da kam ich nämlich gerade drauf, weil die kriegen zu jeder Hochzeit, die sie haben, was sehr viele sind in den vielen Generationen der Bundendrucks, kriegen die immer von so einem Verwandten so ein paar Verse geschrieben. Der Einzige, der die ganze Zeit lebt, alle anderen sterben zwischendurch immer weg, aber der Typ, der schreibt den immer ein paar Verse. Und das ist so was Schönes, so ein schönes Ges Geschenk. Ein paar Verse. Ist es auch, ja, total schön. Ich habe in meiner Nostalgie-Nummer natürlich auch alten Liebesbrief gefunden, den ich damals der Angebeteten geschickt habe und dann dachte ich mir auch so, extrem peinlich und ich hatte ihn auch anders in Erinnerung, ehrlich gesagt, was unangenehm ist, aber muss man natürlich der Realität ins Auge sehen. Aber ist natürlich schön, sowas natürlich mal zu haben, so einen geschriebenen Brief und dann hin. Ich habe mich dann entschieden, da auch noch einen Film beizulegen, den ich als angemessen empfand. Welcher Film war es, den du als angemessen empfand? Fight Club. Und ja, jetzt nicht der klassische Film, mit dem man da Erfolg hat, aber naja, egal, ging nicht gut aus, aber es sind interessante Relikte, weil ich habe da mehrere Versionen von dem Brief geschrieben, deswegen habe ich auch noch einen, den Original habe ich ja abgeschickt, die letzte Version, aber die Fassung davor habe ich noch. Die Version davor habe ich noch, das heißt, ich weiß gar nicht genau, was ich abgeschickt habe, ich war anscheinend mit dem unzufrieden, den habe ich noch nicht abgeschickt, das heißt, meine Hoffnung ist immer noch, dass der tatsächlich Abgeschickte irgendwie besser war und nicht so viel Selbstbeweihräucherung und so ein Bullshit mit drin ist, aber gut. Aber glaubst du ernsthaft, dass du diesen Brief vorgeschrieben hast und dann einen Selbstbeweihräucherungspass gemacht hast, weil du dachtest, nee, der Part, der nicht handschriftlich einen Grossteinsbrief ausmacht, den muss ich rausredigieren? Ja, nee, ja. Es ist auch unklar, wie lang so ein Liebesbrief sein soll. Also wenn du so einen Aufsatz in der Schule schreibst, dann wird dir gesagt, wie lang der ist und dann muss man in der Regel strecken. Und man lernt eigentlich als Schüler von Anfang an zu strecken. Und man hat so einen Streckstil irgendwie auch, entwickelt man, weil man ist gewohnt, alles was ich schreibe muss maximal lang und immer noch eine Floskel und noch und zumal dennoch, aber nun sollte man ja doch.
Wir tun Lehrer so leid, die jetzt in Zeiten von KI leben, wo das Strecken so einfach geworden ist. Absolut.
Also ich möchte Schülern gar nicht unterstellen, dass die Jens alles mit KI machen.
Macht es.
Aber ich glaube, die allein etwas original geschrieben zu haben, dann da reinzustellen und zu sagen, okay, bring das mal bitte auf 500 Zeichen mehr, ist so einfach geworden, dass mir Lehrer einfach wirklich leid tun.
Aber Stefan, du denkst viel zu einseitig. Glaubst du, der Schüler ist der einzige, der KI benutzt?
Du meinst, der Lehrer analysiert... Es ist im Grunde reden zwei KIs miteinander und benoten sich gegenseitig und sowohl der Lehrer als auch der Schüler zocken World of Warcraft den ganzen Tag, wahrscheinlich in derselben Gilde. Wahrscheinlich spielen sie zusammen und lernen sich kennen und Organisationen und binden eine Verbindung. Und währenddessen reden die KIs über irgendwelchen Schulkram und am Ende kriegen ihr alle Schüler eine Eins, aber haben auf dem Weg dorthin vielleicht was gelernt. Ja, vermutlich hast du recht. Vermutlich hast du recht, denn das ist genau so. Und dann die AIs spielen auch mit, KIs spielen auch miteinander, während dann eigentlich eine Horde Inder mit einer Horde Inder die Arbeit macht. 70 Bots, sich noten. Ich habe, hat sich nicht 70 Prozent des Internets sind Bots oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung? Ja, Bots, genau, ich glaube, ein großes Problem sind gerade Bots, die miteinander reden. Ja. Also dieses, dieses, hat irgendwie Namen. Streiten einfach. So ein toter Raum des Internets, der mit sich selber zu tun hat und deswegen auch Rechenkapazität verbraucht. Weil du brauchst natürlich auch Serverkapazität für Bots, die mit Bots reden. Und da fängt es dann an, dass ich sage, wo haben Müll, also Internetmüllabfuhr, und da kommt meine Firma, mein gegründetes Startup ins Rennen. Wie heißt es? Tietze Trash. Okay. Trash Tietze. Der kommt, du musst dir vorstellen, das ist wie so ein Müllabfuhr des Internets. Tietze bringt den Müll raus. Genau, also es sind so, wenn Bots mit Bots... Tietze bringt den Müll raus. Okay. Ich stelle schon mal den Müll raus. Tietze bringt den Müll raus. Haut die Bots raus, alle raus. Tietze-Trash bringt den Müll raus. Wenn Bots mit Bots reden, können die bald weg. No, aber espanol. Aber ich glaube, wenn alle Bots weg wären, wäre das Internet dann doch sehr einsam, oder? Ich meine, alle unsere Follower auf allen Plattformen würden ein Zehntel werden. Und dann will ich dich mal sehen, wie du hier mit 17.000 Twitter-Followern stehst, und da würde es aber plötzlich ganz klein werden, aber ganz, ganz klein. Ganz, ganz klein. Und manche haben, Billie Eilish hat vielleicht noch acht Follower. Was meinst du, wie die guckt, was die für Krokodils Tränen weint, die Arme, wenn Billie Eilish merkt, wow, von meinen 70 Millionen Followern waren alle Bots bis auf acht. Ich habe acht Fans, ich habe acht Fans. Meine ganzen Platten wurden alle von Bots gekauft, alle Streams auf Spotify sind alle Bots, alle Bots, eigentlich mag mich niemand, aber trotzdem bin ich Headliner auf Coachella und super berühmt, angeblich, weil es nur Bots sind. Ich glaube, da gucken sich einige Leute an, Matthew McConaughey, Matthew McConaughey, also da sind Leute, möchte ich nur mal sagen, die sich da wirklich umgucken müssen, wirklich umgucken, weil niemand will wissen, wie viele von seinen Followern wirklich Bot sind. Wir müssen uns vor allem umgucken. Ich musste neulich so lachen, weil man kriegt ja sehr viel mit gerade. Weltpolitisch aus dem Weissen Haus kommt viel raus. Dröhnt es. Dröhnt es, es ist eine Kakophonie. Und dann habe ich so ein Video gesehen, wo ich dachte, okay, was ist jetzt wieder passiert? Donald J. Trump soll etwas unterschreiben, hat wieder so ein Dekret in der Hand und so, da wird gefragt zum Thema, was kommt jetzt, weil das war so ein Video, es hat irgendwie ganz viele Aufrufe, Kommentare, okay, was ist jetzt passiert? Und dann wurde er befragt zur Sommerzeit, Winterzeit, weil er will das beenden, ein für alle Mal, was ja auch Bestrebungen gab, vor ein paar Jahren mal in der EU gab es auch ein Votum, wir haben alle votiert für Sommerzeit oder Winterzeit, was jetzt wiederholt werden sollte, weil alle halt für die Sommerzeit gestimmt haben. Zu spät gekommen sind. Eine Stunde zu spät, fuck. Oder zu früh, ich weiß nicht. Ne, es wurde für die Sommerzeit abgestimmt, was aber nicht die richtige Zeit ist, wenn man mal wirklich einmal überlegt. Aber ich auch ich für die Sommerzeit abgestimmt, weil es gut klingt. Aber das ist ein großes Problem bei so Volksabstimmungen, was auch in der Schweiz immer ein Problem ist. Das Wording ist ja immer suggestiv, ist ja immer biased. So, und dann wurde er gefragt, weil er will das auch abschaffen. Und dann wurde er gefragt, für was er sich dann entscheidet und er hat gesagt, er hat so ganz tief Luft geholt und gesagt, ja das muss man sich ganz genau überlegen, da darf man nicht voreilige Schlüsse ziehen, sondern da muss man sich jetzt wirklich mal hinsetzen und die Vor- und Nachteile abwägen und genau überlegen, was da die richtige Zeit ist. Man hält das für eine einfache Entscheidung, aber es ist keine einfache Entscheidung. Und ich sass da und hab so gelacht, weil ich dachte, das ist das Thema, wo Donald J. Trump beschliesst, nachdenken zu wollen und Dinge genau abzuwägen. Nicht überstürzen. Da ist er wirklich unentschlossen, weil das ist ja wirklich ein Charakter-Trait, den man nicht beobachtet bei ihm, weil er immer alles ist direkt und laut und krass und ich mag erst mal und gucken und bei diesem recht unverfänglichen Thema leben wir nach der Sommerzeit immer oder nach der Winterzeit immer sagt er, so jetzt stoppe, erst mal jetzt Grundrauschen aus, da müssen wir sich nicht mehr... Alle Quellen, gib mir mal alles, alle Informationen, alle Dokumente, gib mir mal alle Experten, die wir haben.
So, ich grab mich jetzt mal zwei Monate lang richtig tief ein ins Thema und dann reden wir uns nochmal. Ich glaube, am Ende seines Lebens schaut er auch zurück und sagt, ich habe nur einen Fehler gemacht. Es hätte doch die Sommerzeit sein sollen. Ich habe mich dann doch für die Winterzeit entschieden. Da muss man selbstkritisch sein und dann auch sagen, da habe ich in dem Moment viel zu viel gegolft oder was auch immer. Da muss ich mich selbstkritisch betrachten und sagen, da habe ich mich falsch entschieden und nicht genau hingesetzt und geguckt. Jetzt bin ich nicht der Präsident der Vereinigten Staaten und ich bin das Wissen wir wirklich alle. Ich erwähne es trotzdem nochmal. Ich bin ja jetzt der dumme Töpel, aber das wissen wir, ja, stopp, ja, alle, gibt es nicht einen Mittelweg. Also das eine ist eine Stunde vor, das andere ist eine Stunde zurück. Kann man hier einfach sagen, eine halbe Stunde nach vorne? Also dass man sagt, okay, ab jetzt ist es nicht, es ist jetzt, okay, also du hast 10.59 Uhr, 11.30 Uhr. Nee, und es muss sogar nicht nur, um dir jetzt komplett dich wegzubauen, es muss nicht mal die Hälfte sein. Du kannst sogar 32 nehmen oder 35 oder 37, was halt rechnerisch das Beste ist, um Strom zu sparen und mit natürlichem Licht zu leben. So, das Problem ist, die Welt macht dann nicht mit und dann sind wir so in einer ganz ruhe der Zeitzone und man kommt ja eh schon nicht klar. Als wir immer in den Staaten waren, den Vereinigten Staaten waren, haben wir uns im Flugzeug unterhalten und gesagt, Moment, wann kommen wir jetzt an, Moment, sechs Stunden Zeitverschiebung, ja, aber wir sind doch sechs Stunden geflogen, ja, aber weiss ich nicht, wiegt man schneller als die, ja, dann ist man in so einer kurven Diskussion. Das ist ja schon kompliziert, das nervt ja schon. Wenn wir jetzt das einzige Land sind, was 18.37 Uhr hat, statt 18 Uhr. Können wir da einfach nicht sagen, der Tag hat 100 Stunden oder irgendwie sowas? Also ich meine, können wir nicht einfach komplett alles überholen?
Oder so einfach mal...
Das war ja meine Idee für die Zeit,
die ist ja noch in diesem Sechzigersystem gefangen.
Weg damit, weg mit Sechzigersystem, überall Dezimalsystem.
Sechzigersystem.
Sechzig.
Also eine halbe Stunde sind 35 Minuten.
Also ich habe tatsächlich mal,
als ich klein war, meinen Vater gefragt,
warum hat eine Stunde denn 60 Minuten und nicht 100? Und dann hat mein Vater gesagt, ich bete so sehr, dass meine Kinder in der Öffentlichkeit keine, das würde meine Erzwingte durch sein, in der Öffentlichkeit stellst du mir keine Frage. Ey, sobald, ja wirklich, sobald du ein Kind kriegst, musst du sagen, fuck, ich brauche jetzt noch mal diese Was-is-was-Bücher, ich muss noch mal die Basics. Nee, weil die werden, himmelblau, ich kriege so oft mit, wie Mütter oder Väter in der Öffentlichkeit auf Lautstärke tausend Fragen gestellt werden, die ich nicht aus dem Stehgreif beantworten könnte. Absolut, ja. Und der ganze Zugabteil hört zu, Papa, warum fliegt ein Flugzeug? Und alle so, nehmen mal die Kopfhörer raus. Ja, warum fliegt denn ein Flugzeug? Ja, jetzt erklär mal. Ja, Schatz, also das... Unterdruck. Also das hat was mit den... Papa, warum kann man denn nicht durch Null teilen? Also Schatz, ähm, also du hast... Das Kind, das sich seiner macht... Papa! Das ist ein geiler Charakter, das Kind, das sich seiner macht... Papa, darf ich noch ein Trinkpäckchen haben? 100 Prozent Bewusstheit. Darf ich noch ein Trinkpäckchen haben? Und Papa so... Nein, nein. Ah, wir werden Kinder gemacht. Okay, hier ne zwei, ja? Ja, hm. Was genau ist Zweitschlagskapazität? Hier, willst du noch einen Burger? Und ich habe meinen Vater gefragt,, warum das ergibt für mich mit meinem Kinderkopf überhaupt keinen Sinn. Warum hat die Stunde denn 60 Minuten und nicht 100? Und dann hat mein Vater gesagt, weil man 60 besser dritteln kann. Das war auch deine Antwort auf die Frage. Und in dem Moment dachte ich mir, das ergibt total Sinn. Jetzt, 30 Jahre später, denke ich mir, wann drittelt man denn Stunden? Also wann sagt man, dann lass uns mal kurz um 16 nur ein Drittel treffen, okay? Sagt niemand, dann lass uns mal zwei Drittel vor acht treffen, okay? Gibt's nicht. Ja, 20 nach acht, also ja. Aber 15 ist immer Vierteln. Ja, ich weiß, dass ich das... Und 100 kann man auch vierteln. Ja, du bist jetzt bei mir
angekommen, du bist bei mir
von 20 Folgen angekommen.
Jetzt bist du ich... Du weisst, Stefan,
ich bin dir immer genau 20 Folgen hinterher,
das weisst du. Spoiler Alert, aber du wirst toll
aussehen, den Farben, die du irgendwann analysiert bekommst.
Aber... Und deine Weihnachtsgeschenke
werden nicht enttäuschen.
Nee, ja, ich gebe dir völlig recht, man viertelt, man sagt, drei Viertel zwölf. Ja? Also in manchen... Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, nicht enttäuschen. Ich gebe dir völlig recht, man viertelt, man sagt drei Viertel zwölf. Also in manchen hohen Regionen Deutschlands zum Beispiel. Nicht sogar in Bayern? Ja, ja, Bayern schon. Ich glaube, von der Weirdness-Skala ist drei Viertel zwölf noch vergleichsweise normal, richtig weird ist Viertel zwölf. Das ist glaube ich so Ostdeutschland-Sachsen-mässig, da sagt man Viertel zwölf. Und da ist ja nicht ganz klar, was es ist. Viertel nach oder Viertel zwölf vorzunehmen. Genau, aber es ist natürlich Viertel nach elf. Naja, also da braucht es auf jeden Fall Revolutionen. Hast du denn vor, in die Politik zu gehen? Also wie möchtest du das Ganze umsetzen oder siehst du dich eher als am Seitenstreifen sitzend und hier und da mal was reinrufend? Ja, ja, okay. Getarnt als Comedy-Podcast würde ich ab und zu was von der Bande, ich nehme uns als Bande, Gesellschaftsbande wahr. Wie so Väter, die so einem Kinderfussballspiel zugucken. Wir stehen an der Bande und wir rufen mal was rein. Abseits haben wir eine Ahnung? Nein. Haben wir dabei eine verdammt gute Zeit? Haben wir schon vier Bier getrunken um zwölf? Ja! Sollten wir eigentlich nicht mit unserem Kind im Rücksitz Auto fahren? Sind wir überarmissioniert und rufen zu viel rein? Absolut! Versuchen wir durch unser Kind unsere eigenen Misserfolge zu kompensieren? Hell yes! Ja, es ist schwer. Es gibt manche Sportarten, da ist man höflich. Und andere, da ist man gerade nicht höflich. Beim Billard ist es Ruhe. Eigentlich ist es nicht ein, können wir da nicht einen Grafen haben. Je höflicher der Sport, desto geringer die Preisgelder, je leiser, je lauter der Schottel, oder je mehr, warte mal, je grösser die Teams, desto lauter der Sport. Je mehr Menschen auf dem Spielfeld. Ja, bei Snooker nur zwei Leute, eins gegen eins still. Tennis zwei still. Golf, einzelne Leute schlagen irgendwo hin. Noch viel stiller. Super still. Was ist denn die Sportart mit den grössten Teams, wo wirklich so hundert gegen hundert? Oder will ich so, will ich alle, alle Menschen eines Landes gegeneinander, einfach mal so alle auf. Krieg, ah okay. Nee, aber sowas wie Football zum Beispiel, da sind natürlich auch sehr viele auf dem Feld, 20 gegen 20, weiß ich jetzt nicht. So viele, dass man manchmal einen Überblick verliert. Manchmal einen zusätzlichen Spieler. Ja, das fällt dann auf und dann wird das disqualifiziert. Manchmal fällt das nämlich nicht auf. Manchmal fällt das tatsächlich nicht auf und dann spielen die teilweise mit 30 gegen 20 und es fällt keinem auf, weil die Zuschauer alle betrunken sind. Und wenn die schnell genug laufen und so hin und her springen, das wäre bei der Überwachungskamera, wenn du dich nur schnell genug bewegst die ganze Zeit, geben sie mir ihr Geld, geben sie mir alles Geld, was sie haben. Und solange du dich die ganze Zeit bewegst, können die deren Gesicht nicht sehen. Und dich nicht erschießen. Und können auch noch nicht aufschießen. Und wenn du, das ist nämlich auch beim Blitzer, wenn du eine gewisse Geschwindigkeit hast, kann es nicht mehr geblitzt werden. So über 200. Ja, das stimmt. Versuch mal innerorts. Du musst halt wirklich all in gehen. Wenn du einen Blitzer siehst, kannst du entweder bremsen von 160 auf 100 oder du sagst, nee, dann gebe ich den Rest auch noch Gas und beschlange es auf 200. Warum ist eigentlich innerorts und ausserorts? Warum sind wir da ja immer noch im Mittelalter? Warum sind wir immer noch in in Ortsgrenzen gefangen? Ja, Innerorts. Innerorts. Und manchmal ist Innerorts auch nicht da, wo ich dachte. Naja, tatsächlich nur elf Spieler auf dem Platz, das täuscht. Aber die haben halt so grosse Rüstungen an. Elf gegen elf. Dann sehen die als Mehrerer aus. Die sehen als Mehrerer aus. Die sehen aus wie Mehrerer. Fussballer sind dagegen ja kleiner und schmaler. Kleiner und schmaler, ja. Deswegen sieht es vielleicht nach mehrerer aus, aber im Verlauf eines Spiels, das in vier Vierteln so 15 oder 12 Minuten ausgetragen wird, versuchen Mannschaften aus je elf Spielern den Spielball und so weiter. Es ist zu kompliziert, es ist zu kompliziert. Schaut E-Sport, schaut E-Sport, wirklich, Leute, wir brauchen mehr Zuschauer bei E-Sport. Es passieren so tolle... Aber das finde ich jetzt jemand, der da von außen kommt, zu unübersichtlich. Zum Beispiel Dota. Dota erzählt die besten Geschichten. Unglaublich, erst mal... Es ist unglaublich kompliziert, aber zum Beispiel, also kurze Geschichte aus Dota, ist jetzt tatsächlich vor ein paar Tagen passiert. Es gibt einen unglaublich talentierten Spieler in Dota. Der heißt Parker. Allerdings ist er extrem toxisch, ist ein richtiges Arschloch, ist in keinem Team länger als drei Monate geblieben, immer wieder Probleme. Der hat mal bei einem relativ guten Team mitgespielt, Heroic. Gutes Team, aber jetzt nicht so, dass man sagt Favorit fürs Turnier, hat direkt das Turnier gewonnen mit Parker. Und die meisten Leute sagen, er hat gegen Parker gewonnen. Der spielt Safe Lane.
Was ist das? Das ist für ein Eins-Carry, Hard-Carry. Und jetzt gab es ein Team, wo ein Spieler ausgefallen ist. Kurz wirklich für die absoluten, die nirgendwo angriffen können. Fünf gegen fünf, Dota, Moba, so. Aber das ist gar nicht so wichtig. Nee, aber ich meine, was spielt er für eine Position? Position Eins, aber das sagt jetzt niemand. Ich meine nur, ich behaupte mal, im Fußball können manche Positionen mehr ausmachen als andere. Er ist ein Stürmer auf jeden Fall. Genau, weil so ein Innenverteidiger, selbst wenn er der Weltbeste ist, glaube ich nicht, dass er ein Team so beeinflussen kann wie ein Spielmacher. Nee, ist schon ein Stürmer, würde ich sagen. Und dann gab es ein Team, wo es ein Spieler ausgefallen ist. Und dann hat man sich, den soll man jetzt als Ersatz nehmen. Doch nicht Parker, oder? Der ist toxisch, der macht das Team kaputt, aber der ist wahnsinnig gut, der ist extrem talentiert. Aber will man sich diesen Spieler wirklich ins Team holen, ist man bereit, dieses Risiko einzugehen? Ich meine, sieht man was für eine Toxikness auch manchmal so außen? Ja, absolut, absolut. Also als Zuschauer auch, also er hält auch nicht hinterm Berg. Nee, nee, überhaupt nicht. Und er hat auch Streams, wo irgendwie seine Freundin im Bett liegt und der haut er auf den Arsch während dem Stream und so, während er Dota spielt und so. Und man denkt sich, aber er ist ein extrem talentierter Spieler. Ist es einem das wert? Also man muss abwägen als Team. Und dann haben sie gesagt, okay, wir probieren's, wir nehmen jetzt Parker den Spieler als Ersatzspieler für dieses eine Spiel, für dieses eine Turnierspiel nehmen wir. Und die Spiele funktionieren immer so, man draftet erst, also man sucht sich erst die Helden aus, die man spielen will, fünf gegen fünf, aus hundert Helden spielen wir aus. Können die beiden Teams die gleichen Helden nehmen? Nein, können sie nicht. Und dann geht das Spiel los und dann wird das Spiel... Warum wachst du da rüber? Das liegt zur Geschichte, weil es scheue. Ja, aber okay, gut. Nur mal so, bei Professionellen FIFA können wir ja beide ja einmal dritten nehmen. Nee, das geht bei Dota nicht. Bei Valorant geht das zum Beispiel. Das interessiert mich wiederum gar nicht. So, man kann also den Helden dem Gegner wegnehmen. Wenn man den pickt, kann der andere nicht bemerken. Ja, aber das ist ja spannend. Jetzt gab es ein Turnier. Es gibt Turniere, wo alle vor Ort in einem Location sind, Lahn-Turniere, aber viele Turniere, da sind die Leute auch einfach zu Hause oder in Bootcamps oder in einem Hotel oder so und dann spielen die halt einfach übers Internet zusammen. Parker hingegen, der war ja jetzt nicht Teil des Teams, war nicht direkt vor Ort, sondern wurde quasi zugeschaltet. Und dann denke ich, Parker, das ist ja jetzt toxisch und so, aber er ist nämlich ein guter Spieler. Und dann draften die, picken die Helden, okay Parker, welchen Helden willst du zuspielen? Ah ja, okay, diesen und jenen Helden. Und dann kriegt er seinen Helden und dann ist er eingeschlafen. Dann ist er während dem Draft eingeschlafen. Und der Draft läuft, man hat da so ein Timelimit, wo man seine Helden picken muss und die sagen, wach auf, wach auf, aber er schläft. Wo war der? Der war bei sich zu Hause, der hat einfach teilgenommen an diesem Turnier von zu Hause, er war ja Stand-in und dann das Spiel geht los, nach dem Draft geht das Spiel automatisch los und dann pausieren die das Spiel, aber man hat nur eine gewisse Zeit, die man pausieren darf in so offiziellllen Spielen. Und er ist einfach, er schläft. Und das Spiel geht, das Spiel geht los. Man sieht, dass er schläft. Ich weiß nicht, ob man gesehen hat, dass er schläft, aber er hat auf jeden Fall geschlafen. Und das Spiel geht los, fangen an, vier Helden auf der einen Seite, fünf Helden auf der anderen Seite, ein Held steht noch alleine auf der Spawn-Position, schläft und alle spielen.
Sechs Minuten lang spielen sie und dann sagen sie, wisst ihr was, wir geben auf. Haben die aufgegeben? Aufgegeben. Ich dachte, da kommt der rein und die gewinnen es doch. Ja, aber nein, haben aufgegeben. Wahnsinn, aber ich übertrag das mal. Weil, also ich denke mir die ganze Zeit, völlig zu Recht, Campainen ja gerade viele Leute dafür, dass E-Sports genauso gehandhabt werden sollten, genauso gewertschätzt sollten, warum sind die nicht in den Olympics und sowas. Und ich bin da oft ein Verfechter, weil ich denke, ja, warum ist man so skeptisch gegenüber neuen Sachen, man ist so wenig progressiv, warum kann man nicht diese auch? Aber das sind genau diese Geschichten, die es mir sehr schwer machen als Befürworter von solchen Sportarten, weil es sind einfach kleine Assholes manchmal. Und es ist halt auch so geil, so dieses Team überlegt halt ewig, ist es das wert und er ist zu gut und soll man nehmen und dann schläft er ein. Und man muss einfach aufgebengeben das Spiel, weil man ist kein volles Team. Aber so wie du das seht, das ging es ja wahrscheinlich schon um was und es war ja was grosses. Es war nicht so gross, es war die Gruppenphase von einem relativ mittelmäßigen Turnier. Aber in so einer Turniersituation, wo alle nervös sind, vielleicht davor nicht schlafen. Ja, das ohnehin, dass der Typ einfach einschläft bei einem offiziellen Turnierspiel, als Stand-in in einem Team, wo man ja die Möglichkeit hat, sich zu beweisen
und zu zeigen, okay, ich kann was.
Aber dem ist anscheinend alles so scheißegal.
Wie alt ist der?
Keine Ahnung, 23, 24, sowas.
Parker! Wird er sein.
Und es ist eine ganz, ganz spannende
Gestalt, der hat auch ganz viele
Tattoos von Dota-Helden.
Also der lebt und atmet Dota,
aber kriegt es nicht auf die Reihe,
in einem Team zu spielen. Er könnte wahrscheinlich einer der besten
Spieler der Welt sein, aber ist halt
Das ist ein Wettbewerb. Tattoos von Dota-Helden. Also der lebt und atmet Dota, aber kriegt es nicht auf die Reihe, in einem Team zu spielen.
Er könnte wahrscheinlich einer der besten Spieler der Welt sein, aber ist halt einfach auch ein Arschloch, muss man sagen.
Das ist ja unfassbar. Also ja, das ist schon...
Ja, sehr spannend. Das ist ja wirklich irre.
Aber die Vorstellung so in so einem Sportfilm oder so, dass sie sagen, okay, wir müssen aufgeben, der schläft.
Moneyball, also stell dir mal sowas vor, krasses Spiel, es geht um alles, Riesenrede wird gehalten und dann, nee, Messi schläft. Moneyball, also stell dir mal sowas vor, krasses Spiel, es geht um alles,
Riesenrede wird gehalten und dann, nee, Messi schläft, schläf, können wir ihn aufwecken? Nee, nee, er schläft, kann er denn schlafend aufs Feld zumindest, oder, ja, könnte er, Also er schreibt halt immer F, F, F, F, F.
Er ist anscheinend auf der F-Taste eingeschlafen.
Ja, naja, Dota schreibt die besten Geschichten, ich sag's immer wieder. Na, Dota schreibt Geschichten. Ja. Also das muss man schon sagen. Wie geht's deinem Lieblingsteam OG? Ganz schlecht. Ja? Aber gegen welches Team hat das Team mit Parker gespielt? Heroic. Gegen OG. OG. Das heißt, die haben Deathwin bekommen, die haben das Series gewonnen, jetzt auch nicht so rühmlich, aber ja, mal gucken, wie es wird, die wechseln gerade viel durch, also ich kann jetzt viel erzählen, aber es interessiert niemanden, aber die haben jetzt zum Beispiel auch als Midlaner Stormstormer, was ein deutscher Spieler ist, Stormstormer, und mal gucken, ob das was wird, die wechseln gerade so ein bisschen, die suchen neue Spieler und sowas. Aber ja, ich halte euch gerne auf Launen mit Florentins Kindertisch. Der haut der Mann. Krabbel, Krabbel, Krabbel, Dunkel, Dunkel, Dunkel, Helden, können es Helden aussehen. Ja, ja, der eine ist ein Fuchs. Spielball. Also weißt du, vielleicht das Wort Held ist auch so, wenn man sich Helden auswählen. Also wo ich es schon mal gut finde, so Middle-Lane, Fast-Lane, bla bla bla, gefällt mir gut, so super, abgenickt, Held. Held ist, ja, ein bisschen doof. Ja, stimmt schon. Und dann hat, wie hat Jürgen Klopp seine Helden aufgestellt, weißt du, wie ich meine, das ist halt lächerlich. Es ist in der Tat lächerlich, ja. Seine Spieler, du nimmst einen Spieler. Ja, Champion. Bei League of Legends, die Champion. Ich weiß, aber jetzt ist die Frage, ob es cooler ist oder nicht. Und dann hat Jürgen Klopp seine Champions aufgestellt. Christian Streichel seine Champions. Ich gebe dir jetzt vier Begriffe aus unterschiedlichen Spielen und du sagst mir, welche der coolste ist. Es gibt Dota und Bonus Points, wenn ich sage, für welches Spiel. Ah, okay, gut. Also, dann haben wir einmal Helden in Dota. Dann haben wir Champions, League of Legends. Genau, dann haben wir Agents, PUBG, Valorant und dann haben wir Legends. Auch League of Legends. Apex Legends. Also wir haben Helden, Champions, Agents, Legends. Was findest du am seriösesten, womit könnte man dem E-Sport am besten helfen, mit welchem Begriff?
Icons übrigens, wäre auch noch in dieser Welt. Icons? Idols. Achso, Idols. Idols. Icon League? Du meinst es wie so ein Zeichen, eine Ikone? Ja.
Okay.
Du, mein eigenes Spiel, Legends? Helden, also Legends glaube ich nicht. Ja, okay, Legends raus. Helden, was hast du noch? Hero, Hero, Champion, Agent. Champion ist albern, Champions finde ich richtig lächerlich, sogar wird wie ein Kinderspiel. Agent mag ich sehr, aber wirft das Ganze natürlich sofort in so eine andere Richtung. Weil ich glaube, bei Held bleibe ich dann noch. Es gibt natürlich noch ein fünftes Spiel, das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt E-Sport, aber da heissen die Charaktere Bionicles. Das können wir auch mal Heldungen. Heldungen! Das könnte man auch noch mal überlegen. Aber es ist so spannend, das sind ja sehr spezielle Spiele. Also irgendwie, das ist auch ein Grund, warum man sich dagegen sträubt, um die jetzt zu akzeptieren, als neue Sportarten, weil Fußball ist so natürlich entstanden und es ist so gefühlt die minimalistischste Form eines funktionierenden Spiels. Also alle Sonderregeln will man eher loswerden, jetzt auch sowas wie Torcheck und sowas nerven alle abseits auch eher so nervig, aber macht das Spiel halt besser. Also man hat sich auf die mindeste Anzahl der Regeln, die kleinsten gemeinsamen Regelnenner entschieden, der das Spiel noch sehenswert macht.
Und das gefühlt machen das E-Sports, E-Games nicht.
Dota hat ja so viele Unterregeln und spezielle Mechanics und so weirde, es ist so unzugänglich und so viele Maximalismus.
Wenn man aus so einer E-Sport-Perspektive so traditionelle Sportarten denkt, die haben gar keine Comeback-Mechanics. Also so, dass man sagt, wer ein Tor kassiert, kriegt einen zusätzlichen Spieler oder so, dass die dann einen Spieler mehr haben, um wieder zurückzukommen irgendwie. Weil in so Videospielen hat man oft so Comeback-Mechanics. Du kriegst, wenn du hinten liegst, kriegst du mehr Gold, wenn du einen gegnerischen Helden tötest, damit du wieder zurückkommst.
Du bist zwar schon im Nachteil, aber du hast irgendwie die Chance, zurückzukommen oder so.
Und bei traditionellen Sportlern hatten wir sowas mehr.
Überhaupt nicht.
Bei Fussball nicht mehr. Die liegen 2-0 vorne, die werden ja weiterhin Tore schiessen.
Also warum?
Die Mitte ist ja sozusagen diese neuen Kleinfeld-Ligen, die jetzt so entstehen.
Podolski hat eine, wie heissen die, Baller League, die heissen die Eiken League und so, Tully Kroos hat eine. Und das sind so, da ist vorbei für Florentin, da ist vorbei, er labert mir eine halbe Stunde von Parker rein, aber da ist die Grenze. Ne, und da haben sie ja nämlich, da können die ja ab und zu sozusagen so Tokens setzen oder was auch immer. Ja, ich glaube, das habe ich immer gesehen.
Und dann haben sie mehr Spieler auf dem Feld. Ja, ganz viele Bälle.
Genau, und Tor zählt doppelt oder sowas. nämlich, da können die ab und zu sozusagen so Tokens setzen oder was auch immer. Ja, ich glaube, das habe ich immer gesehen. Und dann haben sie mehr Spieler auf dem Feld.
Ja, ganz viele Bälle.
Genau, und Tor zählt doppelt oder sowas. Torwart Tor zählt doppelt, weiß ich nicht.
Aber die haben so Sonderregeln. Und das ist natürlich flexibler. Ich denke mir aber wirklich, probiere doch mal aus.
Formel 1 ist immer ein bisschen dynamischer, aber jetzt so...
Ja, mit den Bananen, die man werfen kann und so Pilzen, das finde ich schon mal gut.
Aber ich denke mir so, bei Fussball ist wirklich stocksteif.if. Fußball ist so eingeloggt, weil sich irgendwie sehr viele Leute geeinigt haben, dass das die beste Variante ist. Und jede kleine Änderung ist irgendwie frowned upon. Ich habe mir letztens Gedanken gemacht, wie könnte ich gegen die Nationalelf gewinnen. Comeback Mechanic. Wie könnte ich gewinnen? Also ich und meine zehn Freunde, elf Freunde stehen auf dem Platz gegen hier Podolski und Gross und so. Und da dachte ich mir, was man machen könnte, ist, damit es unterhaltsam ist für den Zuschauer, dachte ich mir, immer wenn die ein Tor schießen, zählt es noch nicht. Sie müssen in der nächsten Minute noch ein Tor schießen, erst dann zählt es. Das heißt, sie müssen immer zwei Tore schießen für eins, innerhalb von einer Minute. Das heisst, wenn die ein Tor geschossen haben, haben wir eine Minute Zeit, ein Tor zu verhindern. Wenn wir es schaffen, dann ist auch der Versuch weg quasi. Und dann müssen sie erst wieder ein neues Vortor schießen quasi. Und würden wahrscheinlich trotzdem 20-0 verlieren. Wenn wir ein Tor schießen, haben wir automatisch gewonnen. Gut, gegen die Nationalelf. Unwahrscheinlich, aber da dachte ich mir, könnte man das vielleicht balancen, nur als Idee für den DFB. Ich habe diese Woche übrigens auch gelernt,
warum es Football heisst.
Man fragt sich ja American Football,
hä, die halten den Ball in der Hand, warum Football?
Außer das eine Mal, wo sie dann diese komische Yard schießen.
Das stimmt, das stimmt.
Und dann habe ich gelernt, dass früher,
als Sportarten entstanden sind, gab es ja zwei Arten von Sporten. Und diese Unterteilung, die wir heute ja gar nicht mehr so machen, aber damals hat man die Unterteilung noch gemacht, nämlich Sport zu Pferde und Sport zu Fuss. Und alle Sportarten zu Pferde hießen Horseball und alle Sportarten zu Fuss hießen Football. Also das war schon mal die Überkategorie. Zu Fuss. Das heisst nicht, dass du mit dem Fuss tatsächlich was machst, sondern einfach, dass du kein Pferd hast, sondern per Pedes unterwegs bist. Und an diesen Sportarten hat sich halt Football, was wir kennen, halt durchgesetzt und war dann irgendwann, hat diesen Überbegriff gekapert und war dann einfach Football, das, was man halt meinte. Die beliebteste Sportart war zu Fusse. Innerhalb dieser Kategorie. Wohingegen zu Horseball hat sich offensichtlich nichts durchgesetzt, weil es gibt heute kein Horseball. Ja, trotzdem ist aber abseits der Ethymologie
ist es ja einfach ein fucking weirder Sport,
weil zwischendurch muss man ja doch
irgendwie dann schießen,
wo man auch sagen kann, es macht ja kein Unterschied
für Spielerlebnis.
Zum Beispiel ist es mit diesen Flaschen,
also du kannst ja, wenn eine Flasche
halb voll ist und du wirfst sie so hoch und die muss
das könnte ja auch
anstelle von diesem Fussmoment kommen. Ja, ja. Hat
genauso wenig mit dem Rest des Spiels zu tun,
dass man sagt, die müssen da hin
und müssen einen Pingpongball
in so einen Red Cup werfen. Oder die müssen
halt einen Papierflieger bauen und weiter als
20 Meter werfen. Ja, genau. Also okay,
ganz anderes.
Okay, das ist der Moment des Spiels, wo wir was
ganz anderes machen. Ja. Hat natürlich voll den Reiz, aber ich dachte immer, dass das so der letzte Funken war, um die Namen zu rechtfertigen. Football. Vor allem das musst du ja auch üben. Du bist ja, wenn du Footballer bist, musst du das ja auch im Repertoire haben. Das ist wie meine Cousine, die wollte langlaufen. Konnte langlaufen, die war richtig gut im Langlaufen, hat ihr Spaß gemacht, richtig gut. Nachteil, kein Mensch interessiert sich für Langlaufen. Skilanglaufen. Alle interessieren sich für Biathlon, heisst Langlauf plus Schießen. Sie hatte kein Interesse an Schießen, sie war nicht besonders gut im Schießen, wollte es nicht machen, aber letzten Endes musste sie das machen, weil sie einfach in einem Sport aktiv sein wollte, wo es Sponsoren gibt, wo es Möglichkeiten auf der Karriere gibt, wo Leute zuschauen. Also musste sie plötzlich mit diesem Gewehr rumhantieren und schiessen und das halt mitmachen und wo sie eigentlich nur langlaufen wollte. Das heißt, du hast jetzt plötzlich so einen Anhängsel-Sport noch mit drin, der halt dazugehört. Kann man mit dem Gewehr jemanden richtig verletzen? Ja, klar. Das war ja die ursprüngliche Idee. Die ursprüngliche Idee war, dass du die anderen Teilnehmer abschießt. Ja, stimmt. Dass man sich gegenseitig abschießt. Aber das war halt ähnlich wie die Gladiatoren-Spiele, halt von relativ kurzer Dauer, wenn man sagt, okay, wir massakrieren alle unsere Spieler und dann gibt's halt keine Staffel zwei mehr. Aber dann, wenn man damit jemanden verletzen kann, dann, sorry, aber dann müsst ihr das ein bisschen spannender, das Geräusch aufnehmen. Weil das macht ja wirklich... Ja, wahrscheinlich ist das so ein Ding, damit die keine Waffenscheine brauchen oder sowas. Vielleicht brauchen die keine Ahnung. Ja, sowas. Kannst du aber machen, was du willst. So, das ist das Geräusch. Aber die schi ja bei einem fucking Gewerb. Ja, ja, klar. Dann gibt es ja noch liegend und stehend. Liegend, stehend, ja, ja, und dann die Sonder-X-herrunden. Ich habe es auch nicht verstanden. Ja, ja, genau, das verstehe ich noch, weil das hängt ja lose zusammen. Ansonsten beim Football ist es nicht was gänzlich anderes, sondern das hängt ja mit zusammen. Aber so dieses Eischießen ist schon nicht ganz ohne. Was? Also diesen Football-Ei, dieses Ding, diesen Ball. Du, über die Schwierigkeitsgrade, dieser Randomness in dem richtigen Sport, wollte ich jetzt gar nicht, dieses Fass wollte ich gar nicht auch machen. Das ist nicht ohne. Nee, das ist so mit diesem Drücker, wo du so mit Wasser musstest, so Ringe über so einen Stiel schießen mit so einem kleinen Drückergerät. Ja, dieses Drückdingen, ja, ja. Das könnte man ja auch machen. Was ist da die Moral, Herr Pfister? Gute Frage. Alle Ringe auf den Stiel und dann geht es wieder von vorne aus. Und was dann? Wie geht es weiter? Damit schicken wir euch gerne in die nächste Woche ganz viel Erfolg. Ich hoffe, ihr bewegt euch ein bisschen, geht mal raus, macht ein bisschen Sport, erfindet gerne neue Sportarten, rennt im Kreis, rennt wild. Renn wild im Kreis. Oder legt einfach auf dem Sofa und schaut Buddenbruchs. Hauptsache, ihr macht mal das Körper. Nee, ihr müsst nichts mit meinem Körper machen. Was ist der kleinste Kreis, den ihr rennen könnt? Was ist der kleinste Kreis, den ihr mit maximaler Geschwindigkeit rennen könnt? Renn so schnell ihr könnt, wirklich so maximale Geschwindigkeit, und dann guckt, was ist der kleinste Kreis, den ihr rennen könnt? Schickt das Video gerne im Reddit. Ich schaue mir das an. Das glaube ich, dass du dir alle anguckst und dann kannst du ja den besten küren. Ja, mache ich gerne. Goldmedaille, das Podcast-Ufo, Goldmedaille, Fit kann auch lustig, hatten wir ja vor acht Jahren mal angekündigt, dass wir euch zu Sport tritzen, tritzen wollen. Das kommt auch noch bald. Ja, das kommt bald, machen wir Fit Can auch lustig, wo wir Badminton spielen oder so. Okay. Wir waren, glaube ich, einmal waren wir, haben wir was gemacht. Wir waren einmal Padell spielen. Ja, da habe ich keine Erinnerung mehr dran. Doch, ja. Und da hat mich letztens noch mal ein von deinen Padell-Freunden angesprochen. Wirklich? Meinte, ich war der von Padell. Hat dich jemand... Alles verdrängt, weil wir verloren haben. Kevin oder Johnny. So, macht's gut, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Sorry, wem ab, tschüss!